on va passer maintenant aux choses
sérieuses ar vous le savez certains
d'entre nous certains d'entre nous
partirons en laponie le 29 novembre
chaque jour depuis des semaines et
chroniqueur s'entretuent pour gagner
leur place
la semaine dernière c'était jeudi
dernier d'ailleurs gelé la après un jeu
intitulé sobrement le feu au cul
[Rires]
matthieu delormeau ici présents avaient
gagné son billet au départ c'est raymond
chauffeur-livreur cet équidé panne sur
l'émission confrères semblent surtout
chauffeur livreur
oui le chroniqueur mais le métier de
chroniqueur est en train de prendre le
pas sur le chauffeur matthieu delormeau
on vous a vu choisir un fauteuil fait un
autre et puis vouloir absolument le
fauteuil numéro 7
et si je fais ce geste ça n'est pas
anodin que non benjamin castaldi aussi
il était parti sur le 5 puis très vite
nous dînons se veut le sait aussi où on
the seven up
retour sur une sombre affaire et dans un
instant nous accueillerons quatre
personnes et parmi ces quatre personnes
il ya le traître celui qui a donné le
fauteuil gagnant à mathieu de leur bout
ce tabouret magique sur lequel il n'y
avait pas de faux culs
retour sur le terrible fait divers du
scandale de la laponie
tout se déroule dans la petite bourgade
de boulogne billancourt le jeudi 15
novembre 2018 le pire va avoir lieu sous
les yeux des téléspectateurs de babar je
vais vous demander chacun votre tour de
vous mettre devant un tabouret matthieu
delormeau a commis l'irréparable en
volant à raymond et aux autres
chroniqueurs une place pour remporter le
voyage en laponie
excusez moi ouais je prendrais bien le
sais tu pourquoi c'est le chiffre est
oui sur ces images insoutenables
on peut s'apercevoir qu'il insiste
anormalement pour récupérer la chaise
numéro 7
vous voulez qu'elles vont faire de cette
chaîne pour les premiers gagnante ce que
tout le monde était censé ignorer à ce
moment du jeu un comportement très
suspect qui n'aura pas mis longtemps à
éveiller les soupçons des enquêteurs
qu'il y ait benjamin castaldi qui n'ont
pas hésité à balancer l'ignoble mathieu
la caméra café des gestes avec ses mains
non je ne vais pas vous dire pièce fait
pas un hasard si je me suis rué sur le 7
mai le juge cyril s'est montré
particulièrement clément en refusant de
condamner le jeune homme âgé de 44 ans
sans preuve
alors qui a aidé mathieu a triché qui
est le traître
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent que c'est ce que vous vous
dites
at on le droit de vivre un tel procès à
une heure de grande écoute
eh bien je dis oui apparemment on veut
nous empêcher de parler mais la vérité
éclatera sur ce plateau que vous vouliez
ou non
jeudi dernier nous avons tous été
meurtri oui delorme où vous allez passer
à table nous avons ici quatre suspects
et parmi une de ces personnes se
trouvent
l'auteur du terrible à l'ars marcellus
l'assembly hall atari fabien de lettres
auteur ça fait une dizaine d'années qui
travaille avec moi au départ je n'avais
pas d'argent je le paye en blouson c'est
vrai aujourd'hui
maintenant que j'ai de l'argent je le
paye plus merci mon bébé d'être là à
côté olivier habib
c'est lui qui m'a fait démarrer sur
comédie je travaille maintenant avec moi
il est producteur artistique c'est à
dire qu'il produit tout ce qui est
artistique
[Rires]
alexandre que j'aime énormément
responsable fruits et légumes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
assistant de production que j'aime
beaucoup et en qui j'avais fondé
beaucoup d'espoirs et enfin françoise
spécialistes pyrotechniques je ne
connais pas et c'est très sympa d'être
venu vous oeuvré dans l'ombre et ben
écoutez vous n'allez pas le rester
longtemps
parmi ces quatre personnes se trouve la
personne qui a donné le tabouret gagnant
à matthieu delormeau mal les vacances
nous sommes dans direct si les
téléspectateurs nous rejoignent sachez
que nous vivons un moment d'une grande
intensité sur s'est vite dans ses pmp
alias touche pas à mon poste
jeudi dernier si vous nous rejoignez
faisait une sélection pour la laponie
matthieu delormeau aurait triché aurait
matthieu delormeau et riche il n a
entendu où vous dites normales mais qui
qui est son complice
parmi ces quatre personnes il ya le
coupable
kerron merci d'être là c'est fini que
pour ça moi thibault merci d'être avec
nous si thibault de montalembert qu'on
retrouve thomas très contact très grands
comédiens les chéris quelques coupables
et surtout les fonctions
quelles sanctions doit-on prendre
andermatt ur de l'homme aussi sur les
téléspectateurs qui vont dessiner jette
les seuls juges
c'est vous qui jugez les loups alors
matthieu delormeau
il n'y a pas 36 solutions
nom d'une pipe en bois au nom je
rappelle valérie bénaïm que la pipe est
dangereuse pour la santé
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr sa toque si matthieu delormeau
peut-être pour ne plus à graver votre
cas peut-être qu'il vaut mieux dire aux
téléspectateurs un qui vous a aidé dans
quelles circonstances et vider votre sac
et que le sac aurait été déjà bien vu
qu'ils voulaient parler du cerveau
mathieu détenus la vérité est ce que le
coupable et parmi ces 4 est ce qu'on
vous a aidé est-ce que matthieu
delormeau a triché
est-ce que matthieu delormeau tan
horrible personnage les mags à l'image
de makaya sur ces 8 vous ne supportez
pas la compétition la concurrence
pas de bol pour vous j'ai vraiment
gagner mon billet pour la laponie la
campagne et j'irai à moins que vous
ameniez la preuve du contraire est bien
la preuve c'est réel elle est ici parce
que la preuve est humaine
françoise vous êtes spécialiste
pyrotechnique la seule une pianiste
bureau
les médias eux
je vous vois pourquoi le cv donc
spécialistes pyrotechnie d'accord
d'accord
françoise est ce que c'est vous et moi
comme ça non comme ça moi je suis rapide
rare à ces deux heures à d'autres
questions pas l'apanage balbala pas le
pas dans l'immédiat ben je me dis oh non
j'ai envie de dire aux françaises
alexandre je serais très déçu c'était
toi c'est pas moi c'est sûr mais têtu je
dis ouais 19 heures oui je donnais
j'étais avec les chroniqueurs et je
donnais les lunettes et les masques anti
brouillard avant je peux vous dire qu
est ce que vous dites
il donnait lunettes et le cacher gc ca
jeudi 10 ne pourra rien y faire mon
travail d'eric à m'apprendre 15
elle prépare un faux cul cul c'est la
spécialiste floculant t partez partez
partez loin de la bid producteur
artistique phare d'avis de 15 ans il
travaille il a démarré avec moi il peut
pas j'ai démarré avec lui il peut pas de
créer une station stagiaires ses peines
il me crachent à la gueule crache à la
gueule de l'éthique à olivet habib est
ce que c'est vous olivier on est têtu
j'étais dans la cour juste derrière vous
car juste derrière moi donc je n'ai pas
pu voir si vous avez fait un geste
montrant le siège numéro sept noms
n'avaient pas pu le voir mais pas fait
pas du tout fabien
nous aimons fidèle allié où je sais que
fabien de me trahira jamais je ne te
demande même pas où tu étais tu t'es où
[Rires]
fabien la franchise fait il y était il
était pour des raisons qui m'a qu'on
regarde que vous je n'ai pas à me
justifier
pour moi le coupable
ça n'est pas vous françoise ces
spécialistes pyrotechniques
je vais vous dire pourquoi vous ne
pouviez pas être au four et au moulin
vous êtes disculper très bien jacqueline
hoffmann au mail à alexandre
[Musique]
ça n'est pas toi ont peut-être que c'est
toi non alexandre puisque le coupable
c'est lui un nom aux luttes et hamid
mais non vingt ans de carrière qui voit
sa carrière
en direct après une erreur monumentale
olivier habib habitus à bidart et le
connu sous le nom du magouillage olivier
habib est ce vous qui avez montré le
chiffre 7 à mathieu de leur moi qui lui
avais donné le bon fauteuil
alors oui c'est moi
honteux les ordures sous la pression de
mathieu présent quoi alors l'april
association de mathieu qui depuis le
premier before essaie de me soutirer des
informations
et cette fois ci il m'a proposé vous
connaissez c'est impossible
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau l'aggraver par
d'autres cas il a profité que j'avais un
problème financier
non on m'a proposé ça fait vingt ans que
ça dure la somme de 10 euros payable en
deux fois
payable en deux fois je quitterais cible
je n'ai rien calculé
ça doit être bien alors et donc été
acceptée
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours rien perçu pour
montrer aux téléspectateurs ce que vous
lui avez fait exactement l'effet se
signent là exactement 1 2 3 4 5 6 me
tape du numéro matthieu delormeau
vous êtes accusé
ce sont les téléspectateurs qui vont
décider est ce que je la garde vous
allez vous défendre à l'instant mais je
vous dit votre défense pouvait la photo
qu ils ont été les spectateurs qui vont
décider s'ils vont décider du sort de
mathieu delormeau doit-il partir en
laponie
oui ou non la réponse est simple la
réponse est claire
la réponse est limpide un peu de
mansuétude chef deuxième chance je le
comprends pas ce que vous dites je n'ai
pas de monstration est-ce que vous avez
une défense si le geste a été fait je
n'ai pas vu moi je ne les ai pas vus
c'est bien le seul à non vraiment c'est
le geste a été fait je n'aimais pas du 7
doigts à non débat n'ait pas vu cette
doit donc a je ne les ai pas vus 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur moment ça en est nous sommes
à faire est trop grave
le juge verdès derrière votre sourire
d'ange un peu niais et derrière votre
sourire d'ange se cache le mal vous êtes
magnifique mais non c'est avec du public
vous êtes le joker depuis le début vous
truquez les épreuves moi je me suis
battu pour aller en laponie
c'est mon rêve monsieur j'ai même perdu
en finale une épreuve contre montiel en
déshonorant ma famille voilà et vous
vous avez truqués toutes les épreuves
même olivier olivier vous c'est pire que
tout mais oui ah non mais à chaque petit
sourire avec moi non mais vous regardez
moi olivier vie vous vous m'appelez tous
les jours pour faire des épreuves pour
que je mouille le maillot et tout est
truqué par lui et vous acceptez ça mais
moi je vous le dis franchement matthieu
delormeau
si vous allez en laponie si les gens
vont pour vous je quitte à jamais cette
salle voilà enfin parce que les
audiences
vous décidez chez vous gb jamais
exactement leur dis pas une de plus ça
veut dire quelque chose et nous non
d'aller trop dit ou pas ces faits mais
damon ya plus de bébés il n'y a plus de
beda plus de b mais j'avoue j'ai triché
museler fait pour toi
ah oui c'est vrai que depuis la première
émission je laisse ouvriers et à chaque
fois qu'il montait
un soir
la gauche votre magic
c'est vrai que tu demandé à chaque fois
cela dit petit à quoi vous l'avez fait
d'abord il m'a donné le chiffre à 500
avocats me le dire alors là et si j'ai
fait ce beau gâteau est prévu que huit
épreuves d'avions pris 80 balle est fait
pour toi on pas que tu partes seul pour
patrick daniel moreau et m'a mis
ensemble à la peau ni pourquoi convives
quelque chose tous les deux et on va on
va dire on peut plus quelque chose à
distance voilà c'est pourtant que j'ai
fait c'est pas pour moi j'ai pris ces
risques la ccbbo fiel mon avis c'est par
amitié et par amitié ghoul a fait
l'amour l'action sur l'amitié ça
m'arrange enfants clément du coup sûr le
vote sanction
écoutez c'est bon il a avoué oui mais
faut avouer à demi dans son lit à ces
femmes canon pas faute avouée à moitié
pardonnée
ah oui olivier habib vous serez jugés
demain à venez à l'aube lorsque le
derniers rayons du soleil se rassurent
la dernière montagne du limousin filet
dans l'hers le crépuscule regardez pas
l'anc est encore hautement monnaies
[Rires]